merci de votre présence
d'abord nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir madame domélix Simonneau
contre leur général des lieux de
privatise des lieux privatifs de
privation de liberté je vais y arriver
excusez-moi nous devions avoir également
ce matin même la ministre Sonia baqueste
qui est du s'excuser car convoqué au
Conseil des ministres et donc de ce fait
ne pouvait pas être présente
ne rajoutez pas
bien même la contrôleur chaque année
vous venez devant la commission des lois
nous présenter votre rapport
vous savez que c'est un sujet sur lequel
la Commission est
sensible
puisqu'elle suit régulièrement la
situation dans les milieux privatifs de
liberté
qu'au-delà simplement
de
des aspects budgétaires en fin d'année
sur les conditions
financières tout au long de l'année nous
exerçons des visites des déplacements
les plus récents
se sont fait la prison de Bordeaux
Gradignan il y a quelques semaines
quelques mois
peut-être qu'on pourra incarcéré
quelques collègues qui parlent trop je
sais pas c'est une idée
et donc
bien sûr visiter ce site et puis
également
Bao ou nous étions en Guadeloupe et du
coup son Martinique
plus récemment et un peu plus d'un mois
et demi ce qui sont les expériences les
plus récentes de façon j'allais dire
officielle de la commission des lois
d'autres collègues ont pu aller
évidemment dans d'autres lieux de
progressifs de liberté
il y a les questions qui se posent comme
d'habitude les questions de l'état
matériel de certains bâtiments des
questions liées à la surpopulation
carcérale et c'est peu de le dire
lorsque l'on parle de Gradignan la
question évidemment que qui est débattue
de l'augmentation des places du lieu
privatif des libertés
qui s'opposent à l'idée qu'il faut faire
de la régulation carcérale et donc ne
pas incarcérer tout le monde
en même temps avoir une politique de
tolérance zéro annoncé partout tout ça
est parfois un peu d'injonction
paradoxale mais on va d'abord vous
écouter et puis ensuite j'imagine bien
que chacun vous posera les questions
alors vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président et merci de
m'avoir invité remarqué
et bonjour mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et
on est assez ému en de référendié moi
toujours de
comparaître mais de venir raconter notre
histoire l'histoire de des lieux
conviviite ici
la représentation la plus haute de la
nation parce que
ce qu'on voit ce qu'on constate et qu'on
rend tout public comme vous le savez
tout ce qu'on voit est rendu public
après une phase contradictoire envoyée
aux autorités de tutelle ou au ministre
de qui d'ailleurs parenthèse on a
parfois pas de réponse notamment là on
est en attente de la réponse du ministre
de l'Intérieur sur ce qu'on lui a envoyé
sur les centres de rétention
administratives c'est-à-dire des
recommandations en urgence mais c'est
pas par les centres de rétention
administratif peut-être que je vais
commencer mais par les prisons comme
vous comme vous l'avez fait monsieur le
Président sur les prisons je vous l'ai
dit quand on s'est vu en préparant cette
visite aujourd'hui
chaque fois que je rentre dans une
prison je me dis bah cette fois j'ai
touché le fond et ben non le fond est
toujours plus loin alors
je sais que on peut opposer sur
population carcérale laxisme de la
justice
construction de place de prison
tous ces comme vous le dites toutes ces
injonctions contradictoires
en cours en ce moment
je rapproche le micro oui ce sera ce
sera mieux oui parce que moi aussi ça
moi aussi ça me casse les oreilles
mais non mais j'ai l'impression qu'il me
parle
voilà
et donc
chaque fois que je visite une prison je
pense avoir touché le fond mais non le
fond est toujours plus loin parce que
moi je suis allée à Gradignan l'an
dernier Bordeaux Gradignan
comme vous avez pu voir l'état de cette
prison c'est là que j'ai rencontré des
surveillants qui m'ont dit moi détenus
je refuserais de rentrer dans ces
cellules donc on leur disait oui mais
quand les détenus refusent de rentrer
dans la cellule vous leur mettez un
compte-rendu d'incident et il passe au
prétoire et après ils vont mitard on dit
oui mais c'est comme ça mais n'empêche
qu'on refuserait c'est trop horrible on
travaille dans une détresse absolue
Bois-d'Arcy après je me suis dit mais là
j'ai touché le front également parce que
là j'ai regardé je sais pas des vous
voyez une prise qui sort du mur elle a
une prise à laquelle s'accroche un fil
de multiprise à la auquel s'accroche des
dizaines de fils avec des multiprises et
on se dit mais ça va sauter un de ces
jours
il va y avoir un truc grave un incendie
et je parle toujours on prend soin au
contrôle général de parler de la
sécurité à la fois des détenus mais
aussi des surveillants parce qu'il faut
bien voir que la vie des surveillants en
prison est un enfer également
je suis allée à Perpignan récemment vous
allez voir sortir d'ailleurs des
recommandations en urgence j'aime dans
une cellule les détenus me disent madame
asseyez-vous puis tout de suite il me
dit non surtout ne vous asseyez pas
parce qu'il y a les punaises de lit à ce
moment-là il remonte leur manche il
manque leur membre dévorés de bouffées
par les vermines
et les surveillants me disent madame
surtout quand vous rentrez pas question
faites comme nous nous aucun de nos
vêtements ne rentre chez nous
on met tout dans des sacs en plastique
on se déshabille sur le pas de la porte
on met tout dans des sacs plastiques et
tout au congélateur pour 72 heures ce
que j'ai fait en rentrant chez moi
heureusement c'était très tard et aucun
voisin n'est passé me prendre pour une
folle avec mes sacs plastiques
c'est quand même
est-ce que ça peut continuer comme ça je
ne crois pas et d'ailleurs je vous le
confie parce que vous allez le voir
sortir bientôt nous nous avons réuni au
contrôle général
des une quarantaine d'associations
d'organisations de syndicats
pénitentiaires de magistrats d'avocats
d'associations qui œuvrent en prison
parce que tous nous sommes d'accord ça
ne peut pas durer
quelles sont les solutions alors les
solutions sont multiples je sais mais
n'empêche que on a trouvé une base de
consensus je crois qu'à part deux
organisations tout le monde est d'accord
pour arriver à une forme de régulation
carcérale qui prendra la forme qu'on
pourra vouloir j'ai vu les amendements
qui ont été déposés devant la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée je connais le
numerus clausus qui avait été prôné par
Dominique raimbour mais aussi par
Jean-René Lecerf qui bon
que j'ai connu quand j'étais journaliste
qui était un type vraiment formidable et
qui a beaucoup fait pour pour
l'amélioration des conditions de
détention
et
je pense que d'une manière ou d'une
autre il faudra qu'on y arrive parce que
j'ai entendu le garde des sceaux
refusait tout net cette solution
dire au sénateur et sénatrice socialiste
et bien vous assumez dans ce cas de
libérer douze à 13000 détenus devant
l'opinion il la redit en commission des
lois oui je sais qu'il le dit il le dit
tout le temps maintenant mais je trouve
que c'est un peu dommage parce que c'est
un peu simpliste parce que il s'agit pas
de libérer
tous.000 détenus comme il le dit dans
ton menaçant ce qui
ce qui est fait pour faire peur et pour
impressionner et pour vous dire
évidemment j'aimerais vous n'allez faire
ça parce que vous allez vous heurter à
vos électeurs vous vous ne pourrez pas
l'assumer c'est impossible
alors que les mécanismes qui sont
proposés sont beaucoup plus je dirais
malin que ça et
il ressemble à ce qui a été fait pendant
les ordonnances covides ou plus ou
prendre plus de temps peut-être pour
pour voir comment juguler les entrées
et favoriser les sorties sous conditions
sous contrôle d'un juge d'application
des peines sous contrôle des services de
probation et d'insertion tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que actuellement
la prison est comme tout ce tient
puisqu'on va parler de la psychiatrie
également
tout se tient la prison est en train de
devenir un énorme asile psychiatrique
non pas à ciel ouvert mais si elle
fermait on évalue à plus de 30%
le nombre de gens souffrant de troubles
graves psychiatriques qui sont enfermés
en prison
faisant jouer au surveillant comme
odetenus le rôle d'infirmier
psychiatrique ce qu'ils ne sont pas
on a des témoignages de détenus qui nous
racontent que se levant la nuit
pour faire pipi se heurte au corps
pendu d'un coup détenu où il nous
raconte des scènes épouvantables de
détenus qu'on leur impose dans leur
cellules et qui hurlent du matin au soir
et dont ils ne veulent plus et qui
finissent par repousser de leur cellules
ils ont honte de cette réaction enfin et
tout ce qui est fait pour
tout ce qui est préconisé par l'article
7507 du code des procédure pénale à
savoir mener en prison une vie le plus
proche possible de celle de la société
afin de mener dehors une vie et insérée
et responsable et exemples d'infraction
tout ça est bafoué du matin au soir tous
les jours dans les maisons d'arrêt donc
il va bien falloir qu'on trouve une
solution et je dis oh parce que ce
serait bien qu'on la trouve ensemble et
que que j'espère que vous serez sensible
aux arguments que le CGL PL développe au
fur et à mesure de ses visites
c'est
c'est dommage parce que la prison
pourrait donner quelque chose
d'intelligent pourrait ne pas être un
temps mort pourraient ne pas être cet
endroit où on passe 21h sur 24 en
cellule enfermé à trois dans moins d'un
mètre carré d'espace vital par personne
je vous rappelle que la norme européenne
c'est 3 mètres carrés
moi j'ai vu ça je vous
aussi d'ailleurs vous on n'est pas fier
franchement
quand je suis allée visiter les prisons
allemandes et que je les ai vu à un par
cellule 70% des détenus qui travaillent
en Allemagne contre 28% en France
il y a en Allemagne et en Hollande
huit peines de travail d'intérêt général
pour deux peines de prison ferme nous
c'est la proportion est inverse
mais pourquoi pourquoi on rate tellement
ce que d'autres réussissent et pourquoi
on ne reprend pas ça plus calmement plus
plus intelligemment plus de façon à ce
que effectivement la prison quand on en
sorte et bien qu'on y ait appris quelque
chose qu'on y ait pris le goût de
quelque chose vous savez c'est possible
j'ai entendu des détenus quand j'ai
quand j'étais quand j'assistais aux
audiences raconté avec passion des
recettes de gâteaux de je ne sais pas
quoi et dire que quand il sortirait il
serait pâtissier ou boulanger ça allait
être magnifique j'ai vu
j'ai assisté en prison à des concours
d'éloquence peut-être que vous aussi et
c'est des moments exceptionnels j'ai
il y a 11 à 12% d'illettrés en prison
pourquoi ils n'apprennent pas à lire et
à écrire pourquoi pourquoi à cause de la
surpopulation ils n'ont accès personne
n'a accès à rien parce que tout est
contraint par le temps je vous rappelle
que l'accès aux soins est contraint
également qu'il y a des pertes de
chances du point de vue de la maladie et
de la mort de certains détenus que les
médecins nous ont qui travaillent en
prison nous ont décrit et je pense que
c'est un contentieux dont les avocats
vont s'emparer
ces pertes de chances et ses mises en
danger de la vie à la fois des
surveillants et des détenus que les
médecins nous ont également décrit
en parlant notamment de décompensation
psychique de la part des détenus comme
des surveillants
peut-être
qu'est-ce que tu vois d'autre André à
dire sur les prisons
je crois que oui
je peux vous parler des centres de
rétention administratif puisque demain
vous allez voir sortir des
recommandations en urgence qu'on a
faites sur quatre centres de rétention
administratives qu'on a visité qui sont
les centres de 7 de Metz
de Lyon 2 et du Menil Amelot
et moi personnellement je suis allée à
Sète et à Lyon
j'ai commencé par un truc qui m'a laissé
scotcher
sa première fois que je vois sur des
murs dessiner des croix gammées en caca
et qui ne sont pas nettoyés
et quand j'ai parlé au chef de centre
j'ai dit Monsieur dans les chambres de
mise à l'isolement c'est-à-dire les
jambes de mise à l'écart qui est déjà
sont assez dégoûtantes il faut que je
vous le dise des croix gammées dessinées
avec des excréments et que personne
n'ait eu l'idée de les effacer
ça je trouve que ça
prédispose mal du lieu qu'on visite je
sais pas comment vous dire vous sentez
tout de suite pas très bien
outre le fait que
les lieux sont dégradés très dégradés
le chef de zone avait l'air très surpris
qui est ses croix gammée au mur mais il
y avait pas que des croix gammées
dessinées avec les mêmes matières et qui
n'étaient pas nettoyées d'où peut-être
l'odeur pestile l'ancienne qui
s'échappait des lieux
c'est dans les chambres de mise à
l'écart là où on met les gens pour qu'il
se calme
ça me paraît dur de se calmer mais bon
peut-être ensuite
il y a ce qu'on appelle dans les cas les
zones de vie qui sont des zones sans
surveillance parce que voyez-vous les
crasses sont confiées à la garde des
policiers et
les policiers leur métier n'est pas la
garde leur métier c'est le maintien de
l'ordre et les lucidations des crimes
des délits des infractions
je pense que comme l'a dit à
syndicaliste parce que je me suis fait
reprendre par le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur le fait que c'était pas leur métier
mais que j'avais pas à dire que que
la garde n'était pas le métier des
policiers mais c'est repris par des
syndicalistes hier j'ai rencontré les
syndicalistes d'alliance qui sont pas
parmi les plus disons on n'est pas les
plus proches et ben on est bien tombé
d'accord sur ce fait
ça n'est pas le métier des policiers il
faudrait donc les policiers ils
redoutent ils redoutent les retenues les
retenues redoutent les policiers ça crée
une ambiance
explosive dans les dans les centres de
rétention
et personne les policiers entre le moins
possible et on leur demande d'entrer le
moins possible dans les zones de vie
donc les arrivants sont arrivés avec
leurs paquetage à la porte fermée de la
zone de vie qui s'ouvre ils sont envoyés
là-dedans tout seul et c'est aux anciens
de leur apprendre ce qui va se passer
là-dedans les portes ne sont pas fermées
les portes des chambres donc il y a des
intrusions nocturnes et c'est un peu la
loi du plus fort qui règne
je rappelle également que
la rétention administrative nous coûte
très cher
d'après la Cour des comptes elle elle
coûte 690 euros par jour et par retenu
c'est un chiffre dont André et moi on
est allé demander des comptes à la Cour
des comptes en disant mais vous avez
écrit ce chiffre vous pouvez nous
expliquer comment vous avez sorti ce
chiffre alors ils ont pas pu nous le
détailler ce que je trouve un peu
dommage on a trouvé un peu
dommage mais ils maintiennent ce chiffre
et ils disent qu'il est exact en tout
cas je rappelle que la rétention elle
est prévue pour être pour le temps
strictement nécessaire à l'éloignement
comme vous le savez
le ministère de l'Intérieur ne publie
plus le chiffre des
occultés F qui sont délivrés
et pourquoi et pourquoi c'est parce que
on verrait le ratio entre le nombre
d'occuts et le nombre de d'éloignements
réalisés et je crois que
frôle péniblement les 10%
que il y a de plus en plus de sortants
de prison dans les centres de rétention
ce qui augmente la peur des policiers et
l'ambiance dégradée dans les centres de
rétention
moi j'ai vu des retenues s'accrocher à
moi et me dire Madame s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi à retourner en prison c'était
le paradis c'est pour vous dire mais le
fait est que pourquoi les démarches ne
sont-elles pas entreprises quand les
gens sont en prison pour que les
expulsions pour éviter le passage par le
centre de rétention qui est à la fois
c'est une ambiance horriblement
anxiogène parce que les gens
mine de rien ils jouent leur vie
là-dedans et est-ce qu'ils vont être
envoyés dans leur pays ou pas il y a
aussi tout le problème des jeunes
anciens jeunes anciens mineurs non
accompagné à qui des gens très
intelligents ont soufflé des conseils
très malins du style ne donne pas ton
pays d'origine dictée algérien alors tu
es tunisien déchirent tes papiers ce qui
fait que nous on est tombé au centre de
rétention de 7 sur un gamin qui avait 19
ans qui sanglotait du matin au soir il
voulait rentrer en Tunisie et bien ça
n'était plus possible et à mon avis il
rentrera jamais en Tunisie d'abord la
Tunisie reprend pas ses ressortissants
ou très peu ensuite aucune trace de lui
aucun papier de lui venant de Tunisie et
ils sont placés dans une situation
son père était en train de mourir là-bas
il pleurait il pleurait les armes de son
corps ensuite je signale autre chose à
la visite de Lyon c'est la première fois
qu'on fait deux articles 40 en une seule
visite
dont l'une
parce qu'il y a un problème de médecine
dans les cas là les hospices civils ont
abandonné le gras la convention entre le
crâne et les Hospices Civils de Lyon à
sauté c'est confié au privé il y a un
médecin deux après-midi par semaine
c'est tout
alors que les gens sont souvent dans des
états très déprimés
et physiquement pas génial et surtout on
a vu des infirmières distribuées à tour
de bras un médicament qui s'appelle le
Lyrica je sais pas si vous le connaissez
c'est fait pour soigner les neuropathies
douloureuses et les accès de et les
crises d'épilepsie et ces distribués à
60% de la population du crâne qui sont
majorité des hommes jeunes ce qui rend
absolument impossible le fait que 60% de
jeunes personnes soient atteinte de ces
pathologies et de fait sont des calmants
puissants qui se revendent à 8 euros le
comprimé à travers le crâne il y a un
trafic mais qui est favorisé par le fait
que sans aucun coup contrôle
ces médicaments sont distribués comme ça
bon sans compter le trafic de shit dont
je vous parle pas parce que ça il a lieu
en prison aussi bien sûr
voilà on a également trouvé dans cette
dans ce centre de rétention des
instruments de contention
qui nous ont paru on a demandé mais vous
en servez on nous a dit oui si en cas de
besoin ce qui alors là totalement
illégal
je sais pas comment c'est possible
et puis les policiers nous expliquent
tout le mal qu'ils ont à
accompagner les retenues dans les
centres dans les dans les tribunaux pour
les audiences devant les juges de la
liberté et de la détention
une petite parenthèse pour le centre de
Sète
le local avocat
pour le JLD a été construit dans les
anciennes toilettes du palais de justice
ce qui donne non mais une idée de
l'espace je parle pas du symbole de
l'espace
qui est laissée à l'avocat et à son
client pour s'entretenir
voilà donc il faudrait peut-être veiller
à plus de rationalisation or c'est une
politique désormais malheureusement
assumer par le gouvernement à savoir des
allers-retours entre les centres de
rétention et la prison qui fait que ça
participe de la surpopulation carcérale
il y a environ 500 détenus à Seysses qui
tournent entre le centre de rétention et
la prison
les surveillants appellent ça le
phénomène des portes tournantes et sauf
que voilà montre que si on doit expulser
quelqu'un et ben que les démarches aient
lieu depuis la prison ce serait quand
même un peu plus intelligent
et un peu plus rationnel et ça éviterait
peut-être que qu'on soit obligé ou qu'on
se dise obligé de construire autant de
centres de rétention qui coûte quand
même faut quand même faire le ratio
utilité finance publique et là où on
veut faire des économies il y en aurait
peut-être à faire là aussi de même qu'en
prison un détenu nous coûte 110 euros
par jour et par et bien c'est sans
compter le coût de la récidive comme mes
cheveux je crois que je l'avais déjà dit
comme l'a écrit très spirituellement un
détenu ça fait un peu cher pour
fabriquer de la récitive
merci madame monsieur
la marque
et puis ensuite je vais la liste des
noms
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
contrôleur général s'il y a un endroit
de votre rapport où l'on peut se
rejoindre nous avons déjà dit lorsque
nous pratiquons les auditions pour le
PLF dans le cadre des crédits de
l'administration pénitentiaire c'est ce
sont les effets délétères du manque
d'évaluation parlez bien dans le micro
parce qu'on a ce sont les effets
délétères du manque d'évaluation vous
les relevez et les rapports du Sénat ont
fait le même constat notamment
s'agissant des mineurs manque
d'évaluation des centres éducatifs
fermés manque d'évaluation plus
généralement des courtes peines avec le
risque de solution inadaptées
inefficace et pour les CEF coûteuses
même si j'ai été visité celui que nous
avons la chance d'avoir un environnement
dont vous m'avez expliqué que c'est sans
doute le meilleur surtout si l'on ne
fait pas vous l'avez trouvé comment je
trouvais très bien et c'est vrai que il
y a je crois qu'il y a 12 mineurs 24
éducateurs
et mais ça se passait relativement bien
effectivement j'ai passé toute la
journée avec
surtout si l'on ne fait pas d'évaluation
on ne sait pas distinguer efficacement
entre les cas de réussite et les cas
d'échec et on s'en remet à la chance aux
circonstances au tâtonnements à votre
connaissance aucun mécanisme
d'évaluation n'est prévu sur ces sujets
alors ça n'étonne tout le temps mais on
est un des rares pays où justement on
n'a pas les évaluation en continu pour
les politiques publiques comme vous
voulez vous qu'on arrive à s'améliorer
ça paraît quand même assez aberrant
alors que dans d'autres pays notamment
les pays anglo-saxons la pratique en
continu et c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important puisque vous le
disiez ça coûte cher et il faut vraiment
que l'on s'en occupe deuxième chose un
point cependant sur votre constat sur la
baisse du nombre de détenus pendant le
covid vous dites que cela s'est fait
sans problème effectivement mais on va
revenir à l'évaluation oui mais pour la
sortie mais la situation endort a été
diversement appréciée et les retours en
incarcération pour réitération ou
récidive ont été nombreux plus qu'une
régulation carcérale ne faut-il pas
développer les spips un appui au mag
pour le prolonger de la peine pour
éviter si cela était adapté en cas
d'espèce en cas d'espèce pardon la
détention provisoire et les courtepins
de prison mais aussi un appui des
condamnés pour la réassorti la
réinsertion voir l'aménagement des
peines là aussi pas d'évaluation encore
une fois franchement on se demande
vraiment où on veut en la matière enfin
un autre
une je souhaiterais enfin avoir votre
point de vue sur l'importante réforme de
l'administration pénitentiaire en cours
avec le passage des catégories C AB pour
le corps d'encadrement et d'applications
et B AA des agents du corps de
commandement parallèlement des
mécanismes tendons de favoriser les
recrutements dont la création de
surveillants adjoint est prévue comme
pensez-vous et quel regard portez-vous
sur l'évolution de l'administration
pénitentiaire sachant que nous avons du
mal à recruter des surveillants
pénitentiaires que l'admission est faite
à un niveau extrêmement bas qu'il s'agit
ensuite pour ces gens-là des fois de
donner des rapports de rédiger des
rapports
ou du moins de te dire à des gens qui
savent rédiger les rapports on va être
quand même juste jusqu'au bout sur la
qualité de certaines recrutements
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
merci monsieur le Président canner la
parole oui madame la contrôleur général
merci pour votre propos à toi contrôleur
général
bientôt mais
madame la contrôleur général
merci pour votre propos introductif et
je voudrais revenir sur votre analyse
concernant les centres de rétention
administratif que j'ai eu l'occasion il
y a deux mois maintenant de visiter le
centre de Lille Lesquin sur l'aéroport
de de Lille et j'étais extrêmement
choquée par l'évolution de ce crack que
j'avais connu il y a quelques années
accueillant des familles je dirais pas
dans une ambiance sympathique mais dans
un climat quand même assez humaniste
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que des hommes
essentiellement des sorties de prison
d'ailleurs je crois que 96% aujourd'hui
des
occupants sont des hommes et
majoritairement des solides prisons dans
le cas d'une volonté du
le ministère de l'Intérieur en la
matière et ça a changé totalement la
situation
j'ai eu j'ai auditionné discrètement des
policiers est-ce que ce sont des
policiers qui étaient très inquiets de
du climat d'insécurité premièrement
deuxièmement les conditions d'accueil se
sont très largement dégradées sur le
plan physique et puis
j'ai découvert comme quand on apprend
tous les jours qu'il y avait trois
cellules terreaux cellules excusez-moi
des chambres des chambres Terreaux et
que dans la mesure où Jupiter et bien au
bout je ne sais plus de combien de mois
il repartait dans la nature certes avec
un contrôle judiciaire mais il repartir
dans la nature et donc il y avait deux
afghans repérés terreaux qui allait
repartir sur entre guillemets le terrain
neutre de leur vie habituelle dans
quelques dans quelques semaines donc je
voulais avoir votre sentiment sur cette
évolution que moi j'estime très négat
IVe et qui montre finalement que l'écra
aujourd'hui sont devenus des lieux
particulièrement anxiogènes et
particulièrement sûrement porteur de
problématiques nouvelles pour les
territoires concernés en la matière
le Président Madame le contrôleur
général des prisons
ce que vous notez sur la détresse en
prison et notamment dans les crabes bien
sûr
ça touche tout le monde on n'est pas
forcément
on est forcément humain quoi qu'il en
soit quel que soit j'aimerais quand même
que vous ne donniez vos préconisations
concernant les problèmes psy parce que
vous notez justement que il y a beaucoup
de cas de psychiatrique alors quels sont
vos préconisations notamment vis-à-vis
des hôpitaux psy fermés qu'il y avait
autrefois est-ce que vous êtes pour un
retour de genre de choses
vous parlez aussi des démarches qui doit
être entreprises en prison avant la
libération pour éviter d'aller d'être
obligé de finir au cras nous quand on y
est allé avec monsieur le Président il y
a 6 ans souvenez-vous ça avait été une
recommandation prioritaire faites par la
commission des lois bon personne en a
fait grand écho depuis vous revenez
là-dessus
effectivement ça paraît être du bon sens
vous parlez des mineurs non accompagnés
vous dites que vous avez rencontré un
jeune Tunisien c'est rare quand même
d'avoir des enfants dans l'écran puisque
nous on voit au niveau du département
non mais je finis s'il vous plaît au
niveau du département il faut quand même
reconnaître que l'aide sociale à
l'enfance on fait plus qu'il faut je
pense parce que les foyers de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
sont combles sur l'île il y a 270
enfants qui attendent depuis novembre
d'être placé parce qu'ils sont en
situation de grand danger ordonnance de
placement attend
a été rendu et en fin de compte on
attend toujours depuis novembre de
placer ses enfants il reste dans les
familles en grand danger donc on peut
pas dire que on ne fait pas quoi que ce
soit vis-à-vis des mineurs dans notre
compagnie je pense que on oublie aussi
très souvent nos propres enfants ça
c'est ma façon de penser parce que les
270 enfants qui sont pas placés je
trouve
[Musique]
une des remarques un peu diverses mais
qui ont qui m'ont étonné dans le cours
de votre dans votre présentation merci
beaucoup madame Bassa
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la contrôleur
des lieux de privation de liberté je
vous remercie pour
vous je vous remercie pour les éléments
d'approche que vous nous avez
que vous nous avez soumis mais il me
semble qu'il faut plus faudrait qu'on
fasse des
comment remédier à tout cela d'abord et
ma collègue a parlé déjà c'est le volet
psychiatrique vous savez bien que je
visite très fréquemment mais les prisons
et lors de mes visites je constate que
certains détenus n'étaient pas
compatibles avec le régime de détention
et se mettant eux-mêmes en danger leur
code détenu et le personnel
pénitentiaire c'est notamment le cas
d'espèces de Théo Sana dont
on connaissait l'enquête n'est-ce pas et
à la prison de Fresnes qui s'est suicidé
l'année dernière sa famille met en cause
l'administration pénitentiaire pour non
prise en charge du détenu il y a eu une
enquête il y a eu de nouveau un article
il y a un jour mais enfin c'est un vrai
problème
parce que on retrouve ce problème à peu
près dans toutes les prisons et la
prison n'est pas le lieu où on en voit
par manque de place de l'hôpital la base
c'est pas du tout la même chose et j'ai
vu des gars ou par manque de place on
mettait en détention des personnes qui
n'y avait pas leur place deuxièmement et
vous avez récemment constaté des
irrégularités en garde à vue et quelle
est cette histoire de vidéo surveillance
dans les WC et de garder à vue
troisièmement il y a le problème des
prisons de mineurs comme Porcheville et
un Porcheville il faudrait faire quelque
chose on peut pas laisser et ces jeunes
gens toute la journée dans le
désoeuvrement pour ceux qui poursuivent
leurs études jusqu'à l'âge de 16 ans il
y a des occupations bien sûr ils vont en
classe
ils ont droit la médiathèque mais les
autres n'ont rien à faire toute la
journée il se plaignent de la nourriture
il se plaint de tout et il y a beaucoup
de bagarres il faudrait quand même
trouver des solutions et adaptées dans
ces prisons pour mineurs et en dernier
je vous poserai cette question
monsieur Gérald Darmanin vous accuse
d'excéder vos compétences et comment
réagissez-vous à ses propos
merci Madame même la présentation s'il
vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues madame la contrôleur général
je pense qu'il faut que nous essayons
d'orienter notre débat sur les lieux de
privation de liberté d'une autre façon
beaucoup aujourd'hui
je dois dire que malheureusement on peut
s'en féliciter
condamne la situation dans nos prisons
mais aussi dans les centres de rétention
notamment c'est donc devenu un sujet de
nature politique
et qui mérite des réponses de nature
politique
j'ai au nom de mon groupe
déposé une proposition de loi il y a
quelques temps sur la surpopulation
carcérale proposition de loi que j'ai
intégré par voie d'amendement dans les
textes justice du garde des sceaux
dernièrement dernièrement et je suis pas
la seule d'autres groupes aussi déposé
déposer d'amendements et la réponse que
nous fait le garde des sceaux c'est pas
une réponse technique c'est pas une
réponse d'adaptation ou c'est une
réponse de nature politique quand il
nous dit
que libérer
des personnes aujourd'hui
contribueraient à donner du relief je le
dis comme ça à une certaine formation
politique on voit bien que le sujet est
de nature politique donc je pense qu'il
faut un peu effectivement élargir le
débat sur ce sur cette question et y
revenir
plus sur sur le sur le sur le fond après
madame la contrôleur moi j'attends aussi
de vous parce que c'est de votre
responsabilité que vous ne fassiez un
certain nombre de préconisations
pour essayer de trouver des solutions
des collègues l'ont dit sur la
psychiatrie c'est un vrai problème la
psychiatrie et pas simplement pour des
personnes que l'on enferme alors qu'elle
relève plutôt des hôpitaux
psychiatriques c'est un problème de
santé publique la psychiatrie donc voilà
qu'elle pourrait être vos préconisations
en la matière
sur les centres de rétention on est
nombreux et nombreux ici à s'être
déplacé dans des centres de rétention et
je ne reviens pas sur les propos de du
président kaner qui a des biens à partir
de son exemple qui a bien décrit décrit
la situation là aussi je pense qu'il
faut des alternatives à la situation qui
se passe dans les centres de rétention
j'aimerais aussi je crois pas à moins
que je vous en ayez parlé avant que que
que j'arrive et je suis désolé si c'est
le cas mais de parler des Outre-mer
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de la
situation des prisons en hexagone mais
celles dans les outre-mer et à mon avis
beaucoup plus
en hexagone c'est déjà très compliqué
très difficile très inhumains d'agir et
en dans les outre-mer apparemment ça
c'est décuplé donc voilà là aussi il
faut des préconisations notamment pour
les îles il y a la Guyane qui n'est pas
unie comme chacun sait mais pour les
territoires outre
sur sur les mineurs moi je dis attention
un mineur qu'il soit étranger ou
français est un enfant
avant tout donc nous n'avons pas à les
opposer et les enfants
ont des droits moi je me rappelle avoir
rencontré Jacques Toubon quand il était
alors Défenseur des droits sur les
mineurs non accompagnés qu'on appelle
comme ça maintenant avant on disait
minorisé il me disait Eliane le droit
rien que le droit j'aimerais
effectivement qu'on respecte le droit
rien que le droit quand on parle de
mineurs non non accompagné et je passe
et je pense que trop souvent on n'entre
pas
les droits de ces de ses enfants donc je
pense que là aussi il faut des
préconisations bien concrètes parce que
les azeux on connaît on connaît les
difficultés on est bien placé ici les
difficultés financières des
collectivités particulièrement des des
départements qui sont en responsabilité
des aveux donc voilà on va on va si si
on ne fait pas de préconisations à la
matière et là je pense qu'on peut être
nombreux sur tous les bancs à trouver
des points de consensus voilà on va on
va on va avoir ce problème qui va se
réitérer de plusieurs fois enfin qu'il
ne va pas trouver de solutions or je
pense que surtout sur tout ce que j'ai
dit il faut qu'on essaie de travailler
des propositions de fond parce que je le
rappelle c'est d'abord des sujets de
nature politique qui méritent des
réponses politiques
merci de la présidente monsieur Jérôme
Durand merci monsieur le Président
Madame la contrôleur général merci pour
votre travail et celui de vos équipes
qui qui nous est très utile au quotidien
lorsque nous visitons des CRS des
prisons des commissariats la question
que je souhaitais vous poser tiens au
fait qu'avec la Défenseur des droits
vous avez évoqué des dés arrestations
arbitraires pendant les manifestations à
Paris ça vous a valu une émotion et des
critiques de la part du préfet de police
de Paris je voulais savoir quel était le
travail qui vous avez amené à produire
ses conclusions
merci Monsieur Jean-Pierre
oui merci
monsieur le Président
je vais pas reprendre ce qu'a dit Eliane
assassy mais je suis extrêmement frappé
par le fait que ce que vous dites ce que
vous démontrez dans votre rapport ce qui
est public
malheureusement ce hurt a au sa priori
de l'opinion publique et s'il y a des a
priori de l'opinion publique c'est en
partie parce que les politiques que nous
sommes
cultivent c'est sa priori ou ne résiste
pas vous comprenez moi j'en ai
absolument assez d'entendre dire tous
les jours que il y a trop d'étrangers
des étrangers sont un danger si on
entend ça mais 100 fois par jour les
gens vont finir par croire que c'est
vrai
et on a une responsabilité par rapport à
ça vous comprenez c'est c'est terrible
et si on dit de la même manière que
finalement ce que malheureusement
accrédité le garde des sceaux devant le
Sénat moi je lui ai posé à plusieurs
reprises comme tu l'as fait comme
d'autres l'ont fait la question de la
régulation carcérale et il répond à
chaque fois ben écoutez si elle
surpopulation s'approuve bien qu'on
n'est pas laxiste bon mais ça me choque
que le garde des sceaux qui par ailleurs
fait un gros travail pour trouver des
moyens pour apporter de l'argent pour le
ministère de la Justice très bien
soit le porteur d'une vision aussi
fruste enfin on sait bien
c'était Robert Badinter qui disait que
la condition pénitentiaire était la
principale cause de la récidive on sait
bien que quand les gens sont dans les
situations que vous dites à rapport
après rapport ça ne permet pas la
réinsertion ça fait que c'est ça les
enfants dans la situation où ils sont et
qu'on visite les prisons moi je sais
j'ai vu quelqu'un qui sortait de la
prison sortie sèche et demande où est la
gare bah la gare elle est à 300 mètres
mais il sait pas bien qu'il ait vécu
quelques années à 300 mètres de la gare
et si vous avez des gens qui sortent
sans aucun accompagnement après avoir
vécu dans ces cellules de cette
manière-là comment voulez-vous qu'il
s'en sorte c'est absolument impossible
alors ce mythe selon lequel il ne
faudrait pas de régulation je sais pas
pourquoi je ne comprends pas pourquoi
Monsieur Bolin ça a été extrêmement
clair les États généraux de la Justice
ont été extrêmement clairs là-dessus et
ce qui s'est passé pendant le covid on a
libéré un certain nombre de personnes
entre nous si quelqu'un est condamné à
faire s'étendre prison bon si il part au
bout de 6 ans et 8 mois est-ce que ça
change quelque chose par rapport à la
peine ça ne change rien mais si on dit
on réduit l'effectif on met des gens en
liberté qui à mieux les accompagner de
telle manière qu'il y ait sinon
l'encellulement individuelle qui est
dans la loi mais enfin qu'on aille vers
des situations plus humaines je ne
comprends pas ce qu'on peut opposer à ça
sinon l'idée commune que les prisons
sont quatre étoiles qu'il faut les
enfermer et que plus il y a de gens
enfermés dans les pires conditions mieux
c'est voilà et donc ce serait bien si
toute la la classe politique dans sa
diversité pour les immigrés comme pour
par rapport à la question des prisons
décider de tenir un autre discours que
de flatter l'opinion dans le sens du
poil mais ça mes chers collègues je suis
sûr que je demande sans doute un peu
trop
merci monsieur Sueur la dernière
intervention Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie
et puis ensuite Marie Mercier
merci merci président merci à la
Contrôleur général des lieux privative
de liberté de son
c'est bon
non mais parce que je tire le film
de son intervention
moi j'ai un petit peu un problème moi je
suis parlementaire donc c'est la fin de
mon premier mandat mais au fond tous les
ans nous avons
un rapport un compte-rendu sur la
situation dans les prisons sur la
situation dans les cras parfois sur les
hôpitaux psychiatriques parfois sur les
locaux de garde à vue mais finalement
c'est toujours la même chose
et c'est assez désespérant alors bon
Jean-Pierre sur a dit Eliana Sassi aussi
quels étaient les propositions que nous
faisions sans en tirer d'ailleurs de
gloriole particulière parce que
j'encourage la majorité du Sénat a
beaucoup de pragmatisme
ce que nous n'entendons pas nous
n'entendons que augmentation des places
comme si la question d'augmentation des
places allait résoudre le problème
du coup ma question est la même que je
pose tous les anges je les posais à
Jacques tout bon
dans un autre registre mais néanmoins
finalement quel bilan faites-vous de vos
travaux je veux dire que
formuler différemment le garde des
sceaux qui n'est pas toujours
qui a une formulation qui est parfois un
petit peu détendue
donc il n'est pas toujours voilà il
pourrait pas figurer dans le recueil de
savoir-vivre de Nadia de Nadine de
Rothschild toujours mais a dit un jour
on n'a pas besoin d'un rapport
supplémentaire vous l'avez lu Philippe
ouais mais oui mais ça sert finalement
regardez comme je vous parle
courtoisement toujours
un jour en commission il a dit on n'a
pas besoin d'un énième rapport pour
savoir ce qui se passe dans les prisons
ce qui était une façon un peu élégante
de dire qu'en gros vous ne serviez à
rien ce qui est toujours agréable bref
donc finalement quel est votre bilan je
veux dire par là que
voilà c'est quels sont
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé de positif
d'utile plutôt
à l'issue des rapports successifs
absolument effrayant que nous dans nos
prenons connaissance année après année
je n'ose pas poser la question à la
majorité du Sénat parce qu'il y a un
petit peu un double voilà ici Vous
faites part d'un intérêt etc on a
beaucoup plus de mal à vous faire bouger
en séance mais là et Marie me regarde et
Farid en disant mais de quoi
parle-t-elle
merci madame de La Gontrie madame
Mercier
merci monsieur le Président on essaye de
s'exprimer quand
nous nous laissons
utile alors je voudrais poser la
question qui doit aller en prison
certainement pas effectivement les
patients psychiatriques qui n'ont
absolument rien à y faire dans quel état
vont sortir les détenus de la prison
certains pires qui ne sont rentrés j'ai
vraiment deux remarques avec ma collègue
Laurence harribé nous avons visité les
Baumettes les Baumettes 2
c'est une prison neuve c'est une prison
donc il faut aussi bien se rendre compte
de ça quand on visite les prisons c'est
un lieu de privation de liberté sauf que
sauf que moi deux trois cas beaucoup
marqués la petite jeune fille de 14 ans
et demi qu'on avait vu qui était là
parce que l'avait fait bon des crimes
des crimes que nous étions fin juin que
la scolarité qu'elle allait rester cuite
de cette petite gamine qui n'avait
d'ailleurs toujours pas réalisé ce
qu'elle avait fait puisque pour vous la
faire courte elle était
sous une emprise de réseaux sociaux
deuxième
deuxième image qui me reste extrêmement
pour moi très pleine d'émotion c'est
cette maman avec un petit bébé elle se
raccrochait à son petit bébé il y avait
je pense trois trois adultes pour
s'occuper du petit bébé le petit le
petit berceau dans la prison avec les
barreaux à un moment ce petit enfant
allait lui être enlevé c'était juste une
complicité donc c'est cette femme cette
jeune maman elle était visiblement
perdue se rendait pas compte de ce
qu'elle fait on n'est pas là pour juger
ce qui est pourquoi était en prison mais
ma troisième remarque avec Laurence donc
les Baumettes formidables des studios
médias pour apprendre à faire des films
etc et je dois noter le travail du
personnel pénitentiaire remarquable on
arrive à l'atelier Zumba atelier Zumba
où nous avions des jeunes hommes de 35
ans qui faisaient de la zumba et vous
savez à quoi je pensais ce mardi
après-midi à mes petites patientes femme
de ménage mes petites Pat caissière qui
travaille en coupé qui se lève à 4h30 du
matin qui rentre à 7h qui vont poser le
gamin toute cette population des
invisibles qui travaillent je me disais
elles n'ont vraiment pas elle le temps
de faire la zumba le mardi après-midi
donc ce que je voudrais dire par là bien
sûr il faut les occuper les détenus mais
ce qu'il faut c'est préparer leur sortie
les aider à se revaloriser et leur
donner du travail donc Madame quelles
sont vos propositions il faut des
propositions ces hommes qui sont qui
font de la zumba le mardi après-midi ils
vont peut-être devenir des grands
chorégraphes mais il faut leur donner du
travail il faut qu'il se réalise et
qu'ils aident la société il faut que par
leur travail il paie une dette pourquoi
ils sont en prison parce qu'ils ont fait
quelque chose de mal je suis désolé
soyons simples il y a un contrat social
donc leur trouver un travail qui soit
fatigué par un travail physique
excusez-moi de lui dire aussi crûment
mais vraiment je pense que c'est
essentiel pour leur image à eux et pour
l'image qu'il donne à la société
bien pas d'autres interventions
madame défenseur vous avez la parole
merci toutes ces questions alors je
voulais vous dire que la psychiatrie
c'est un énorme morceau de notre action
et donc de toute façon j'y serai revenu
alors je commence par répondre monsieur
Marc sur les CF et l'évaluation mais
c'est exactement ça fait partie parce
que nos préconisations j'ai pas eu le
temps d'y venir pendant mon exposé
liminaire si je peux dire mais oui on
fait beaucoup de propositions et de
préconisations et notamment sur la
nécessaire mais l'indispensable
évaluation des politiques publiques or
il y en a pas aujourd'hui on va on va on
se lance dans la construction de centre
éducatif fermé voulu par le garde des
sceaux mais
on l'a rappelé rapport après rapport et
audition après audition il n'y a pas
d'évaluation de la politique publique
des centres éducatifs fermés celui que
nous avons vu il est formidable on en a
vu des horribles et vous en verrez
peut-être des horribles
oui
je l'ai signalé au président mais quand
ma collègue Brigitte l'herbier a parlé
de fugue dans celui-ci qui est au milieu
des champs personne ne s'enfuit parce
que vous savez ce sont des gamins et ces
gamins là ils ont peur la nuit comme ce
sont des et nous partent jamais donc il
ne s'en fut pas chez nous
et ils m'ont dit Madame parce qu'ils ont
ce joli accent mais on est bien ici mais
si vous voulez s'enfuir mais il faudrait
au monterait sur une vache et on
mettrait des heures des heures des
heures arrivent à la ville
donc on reste on est très bien
l'évaluation effectivement
l'évaluation
est elle est
c'est pas grave et elle est
mais je sais pas comment à quel point
c'est indispensable comment les
équateurs nous le disent d'abord il y a
pas d'études longitudinale de la vie de
ses enfants alors moi je ne dis plus
mineur parce que je trouve que mineur
est un mot qui est destiné à faire peur
parce que quand on dit mineur on dit
forcément mineur en prison mineur en
chef mineur non accompagné mineur fou de
toute façon c'est le mot qui fait peur
et comme je l'écris dans l'avant-propos
on vous au cas de nous ne dirait
j'emmène mon mineur au collège tout à
l'heure
donc les mineurs ça fait peur bon en
tout cas il faut une évaluation de la
vie de ces gamins qui commencent par des
placements à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
qui effectivement ne sont pas toujours
placés mais quand ils le sont madame
vous regrettez que il est temps
d'ordonnance de placement qui attendent
c'est honteux c'est stupéfiant c'est
effrayant mais il faut aussi reconnaître
que parfois les enfants sont placés dans
des familles ou des foyers qui sont peu
ou très mal contrôlés et que c'est un
énorme problème parce que on place des
enfants on retire des enfants à leur
famille parce qu'ils y sont maltraités
et on les envoie dans des endroits où
ils le sont également où ils se font
casser la figure par d'autres plus fort
que ou règne la loi du plus fort et où
il retrouve la violence qu'ils avaient
bien connu quand c'est pas pire et
plus la drogue plus enfin c'est pas pour
faire un mais ça n'est pas possible de
continuer comme ça non plus on peut pas
au doigt mouillé se dire tiens les self
c'est peut-être pas mal on va en
construire 42 plus
il y a une question morale de politique
publique et il y a une question
financière qui est également morale ça
nous coûte très cher et il faut savoir
si c'est efficace de même ce n'est pas
possible que les éducateurs reçoivent
ces gamins sans savoir d'où ils viennent
sans connaître leur vie d'avant et sans
savoir ce qui tiendront après parce que
avouez que c'est déjà un boulot qui
n'est pas facile mais si en plus on en a
pas on en connaît pas les retombées
c'est abaisser les bras totalement voilà
vous me dites il y a eu des retours en
prison après les libérations
post-covites c'est normal et comme me
disait une directrice de prison elle me
disait moi ma elle me sort personne
moi je dis à ma et ben si Sarah tu
une fois on recommence on réessaye on
réessaye il est vrai que les parcours
qu'on appelle de d'existence de comme
vous voulez avec tous ces jolis mots qui
nous viennent
c'est fait d'échec c'est vrai qu'il y a
des retours en prison on va pas le nier
mais c'est vrai aussi que il faut
développer les services de probation et
d'insertion pour rendre effectivement
l'accompagnement à la sortie puis
l'accompagnement une fois qu'on est
sorti je sais c'était mon ancien métier
j'ai commencé éduquer à la pénitentiaire
on disait à l'époque
on le savait vous savez vers 28 ans les
gars il se calme s'ils sont pas calmé
c'est mauvais signe et avant faut tout
faire pour que les encadrer et et qui
s'en sortent mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
renforcer
les équipes des spips peut-être au lieu
de construire de nouvelles prisons je
vous rappelle que la
sur les 15000 places promises il y en a
2000 un peu plus de 2000 qui sont sortis
qui a été promise en 2017
2000 s'en sortis dont celle de la prison
de Lutterbach qui quand même avait été
promise par Michel Alliot-Marie en 2008
quand elle était garde des sceaux donc
c'est dire que la construction de prison
c'est pas pour demain je sais qui est là
il y a des chantiers qui sont en route
mais je ne pense pas que ça réglera le
problème la prison de Lutterbach est
déjà pleine à plus de 190% et elle est
déjà commence à être déjà donné des
signes de dégradation inquiétant
alors la réforme oui c'est très bien ça
je sais que ça a fait c'est bon de faire
passer les souriants de catégorie C à
catégorie B
simplement vous en êtes très conscient
vous l'avez dit c'est quand même recruté
à un niveau très bas 2 sur 20
[Musique]
bon ben
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise il faut rendre le métier plus
attrayant alors peut-être que le faire
passer en catégorie belle rendra plus
attrayant mais c'est un énorme problème
c'est un énorme problème de même que le
métier est tellement dur qu'il y a un
absentéisme et un turnover effrayant
nous partout on visite la nuit il y a
personne si un incendie je ne sais pas
j'ose pas penser ce qui va se passer
mais on traverse même de jour des
coursives sans personne sans surveillant
et moi d'entendre à Bois-d'Arcy c'est un
souvenir qui m'est resté vous savez ce
que c'est passé le drapeau
c'est mettre ces petits des petits
feuillets comme ça avec son numéro de
cellule il passait à travers la porte et
l'agiter ça fait ça fait ce petit bruit
et quand les détenus entendent un bruit
de pas dans la coursive tout s'y passe
les drapeaux parce qu'il y a pas de
boutons d'appel dans certaines prisons
et vous passez de ses froufrous c'est
vite c'est des herbes ils se disent
tiens ça doit être le surveillant donc
on passe vite notre drapeau pour montrer
que ça va pas il faut améliorer les
choses et le métier de surveillance
il est très dur mais c'est vrai que là
il est c'est pas normal ce qui se passe
et c'est pas normal la façon le
recrutement mais pas normal déjà
n'arrive que 26% au concours de
surveillant ce qui a évidemment si on
réussit postier avant ben on choisit
postier avant de surveillant je crois
que c'est le dernier métier qui est
choisi quant aux adjointes surveillants
nous on aimait les plus grosses craintes
parce que si des vrais surveillants sont
recrutés à 2 sur 20 je sais pas comment
on recrutera les adjoints comment ils
seront recrutés
[Musique]
voilà oui nous on émet des grosses
inquiétudes là dessus
ce corps d'adjoint
pardon
c'est pas moi qui donne la parole
tout simplement madame le contrôleur
général en ce qui concerne les
directeurs d'établissement de plus en
plus ce sont des gens extrêmement
humains qui passent des concours très
très
intéressants et en faculté on leur
propose très souvent plein d'autres
choix et celui qui prend ce celui qui
passe ce concours je pense qu'il a une
fibre particulière et il faut les
encourager il n'y a pas que les
surveillants il y a aussi les dirigeants
c'est ce que je me permettais de de
madame merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice parce que c'est ce qu'on pense
également d'ailleurs j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire récemment sur les fiches de
poste
de recrutement des directeurs de prison
il n'y a pas marqué que je sache
cherchant Superman pour gérer prison
ingérable parce que franchement il faut
être surperman pour diriger les prisons
au superwoman les prisons qu'on visite
et nous on a énormément de rapport avec
les directeurs et les directrices de
prison je peux vous le dire on parle
beaucoup avec eux mais là je parlais des
surveillants parce que c'est eux qui
sont dans les coursives au contact le
plus des détenus et que ils sont
franchement désespérés telles le sont
également les directions des prisons
qui par parenthèse
ne voit pas souvent de magistrats passés
visiter la détention que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire au magistrat et ce
qui n'est pas normal parce que quand on
est garant des libertés et qu'on envoie
des gens derrière les barreaux la
moindre des choses peut-être c'est
d'aller voir où on envoie les gens
donc je produis ces visites sans cesse
bon peut-être faut que je me dépêche un
peu plus
donc dans les cas effectivement les
policiers je vous le confirme monsieur
Kader qui est parti c'est pas grave
je vous le dis les policiers sont
effectivement très inquiets ils ont peur
et
les les crasses actuellement c'est le
centre de messe qui accueille des
familles où il y a également des enfants
et je signale que à Metz la situation
est très dure à regarder parce que il y
a qu'une grille qui sépare les hommes
des femmes et de leurs enfants et que
les enfants assistent à des scènes
regrettables de violence d'agression
verbale des sommes sur les femmes
entre leur mère et leur sœur
ça donne pas une image très jolie mais
bon et de toute façon la rétention on va
pas pouvoir continuer comme ça longtemps
parce que je dis la violence s'y accroît
mais la violence la peur et le désespoir
des retenues là-dedans et je vous
prierai de noter également qu'ils ont
faim parce que souvent
les doses prévues les rations prévues
sont pas à la hauteur des marchés et ne
respecte pas le marché public
et bien
madame l'herbier les problèmes si moi
j'allais y venir parce que c'est
c'est une grosse partie de notre rapport
et une grosse partie de ce qu'on fait
c'est une grande nous on va constamment
voir le ministre de la Santé pour lui
dire de rende essayer de rendre plus
attrayant les métiers de la psychiatrie
de recruter de faire en sorte que ce
soit recruter des psychiatres des
infirmiers psychiatriques on traverse
des services où il manque 30% de
soignants ce qui forcément même si on
est là pour contrôler la vie et et
les droits le respect des droits des
enfermés et bien forcément ça jaillit
sur sur la prise en charge de leurs
droits et sur leur prise en charge que
l'isolement et la contention soient plus
employée dans des
ici et là que dans des que dans d'autres
services c'est souvent par manque
d'effectif et aussi par manque de
par effet de routine il faut bien le
reconnaître aussi
les sèves je pense y avoir répondu je
pense avoir répondu
madame Benbassa la psy en prison c'est
une catastrophe comme je vous l'ai dit
on estime à plus de 30% mais là encore
on a demandé au ministre de la santé et
au premier à la première ministre de
diligenter au moins une enquête parce
qu'elle date de 2004 la dernière
une enquête sur sur la santé
psychiatrique de la santé mentale en
prison ça n'est plus possible de laisser
des gens dans cet état d'ailleurs comme
tout se tient ça vient aussi de
l'expertise psychiatrique en expertise
l'examen psychiatrique qui est mené en
garde à vue et qui décide que des gens
sont apte ou inapte
à comparaître en prison
en justice je veux dire
le suicide c'est
la DAP n'a pas l'habitude d'annoncer n'a
jamais su annoncer la mort en prison il
y a 250 membres en prison par an dont
120 suicides on met deux jours à
annoncer à une famille que qu'un proche
c'est suicidé ça laisse la porte ouverte
à tous les soupçons
il va falloir aussi voilà ce problème et
des préconisations croyez-moi on en a
énormément combien on en a relevé André
parce que là André est en train de
construire la base des données des
proches des préconisations du contrôle
général et
nous avons à peu près
5000 depuis la création du contrôle
général à peu près 5000 préconisations
de portée générale qui ont été publiées
dans des documents de portée générale et
sur une période plus restreinte donc que
nous avons commencé au 1er janvier 2017
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 sur les
rapports de visite nous avons 15000
préconisations
touchant les fais ensuite aux visites à
la banque concernant exclusivement des
établissements
dans le suivi annuel qu'on fait
régulièrement
ces déclaratifs donc ne faisons pas des
missions de contrôle pour pour contrôler
parce qu'on en aurait pas les moyens
suivant les lieux on
oscille de 30 à 60 %. mais c'est du
déclaratif quand on y retourne
malheureusement les chiffres sont moins
optimistes on est plutôt de l'ordre du
car
du car 25%
tiens continuons je continue
oui monsieur Darmanin dit que je vous
repassais mes fonctions mais je ne crois
pas parce que dans l'histoire de ces
garde à vue
préventives suite aux manifestations
contre la retraite des réformes je ne
crois pas parce que on a décidé où j'ai
décidé plutôt
qu'on irait puisque les cellules de
garde à vue débordaient on est allé voir
ce qui s'est passé si les droits des
garder à vue étaient respectées et je
pense que ça rentre pleinement dans
notre champ de compétence donc peut-être
je l'ai énervé donc il a dit ça sous le
coup de la colère mais nul doute que ne
le pense pas vraiment
[Musique]
et voilà
je suis pas répondre plus que ça
là dessus
Porcheville oui Porcheville il faut de
toute façon il y a un truc très
important et vous le trouverez dans nos
préconisations également et nous le
réclamons et je les réclamé nous l'avons
réclamé il y a peu au ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'est il faut
absolument un statut de prof dans les
prisons et dans les établissements pour
mineurs pour enfants partout parce que
là un enfant qui rentre aujourd'hui en
prison 600 septembre il aura pas eu il
aurait eu 0 heure de cours c'est
absolument scandaleux ça fait des années
et des années je comprends pas comment
on n'a pas mis en place un statut adapté
pour les enfants enfermés et je signale
qu'en psychiatrie c'est la même chose et
que de rapport en rapport nous le
soulignons les enfants enfermés ont
quatre à cinq fois moins d'heures
d'enseignement que leurs camarades de
dehors c'est alors que c'est des enfants
qui sont déjà fracassés par la vie et
qui à qui il faudrait apprendre quelque
chose alors moi je m'en fiche qu'on leur
apprend mais leur apprendre quelque
chose leur donner le goût de quelque
chose le goût d'un métier qu'on en fasse
des apprentis qu'on leur apprend mais
qu'on parfait évidemment il faut pas
refaire leurs connaissances déjà minimum
mais c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
préoccupant et je ne comprends pas que
que ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas plus préoccupé plus de
monde d'ailleurs il y a un syndicat de
directeur de présence je vous le signale
c'est faux direction Yvan Gombert on a
fait son cheval de bataille également
et ça vous intéresse de le rencontrer il
est intéressant sur le sujet
madame assassin bah oui il faut des
réponses de nature politique j'en suis
bien d'accord
votre PPL va vous savez je l'ai suivi
avec beaucoup d'intérêt et d'attention
j'espère que l'amendement sera adoptée
que accepter de même du côté de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a il y a un
amendement qui a été déposé par Caroline
Abadie et oui et voilà bah j'espère
voilà j'avance
l'écran d'outre-mer en outre-mer nous y
allons une fois par an
nous avons fait des constats
épouvantables l'année dernière sur la
politique pénale et sur les prisons à
Tahiti et sur la politique pénale qui
était qui était suivi et nous allons
outre-mer une fois par an et une seule
fois par an parce que ça coûte très cher
à notre budget que il n'est pas
extensible
à volonté
et bien oui monsieur durain oui j'ai
parlé garde à vue arbitraire parce que
des gens avaient été arrêtés pour être
placé en garde à vue il faut que des
soupçons sérieux
nos constats oui se heurte
à l'opinion publique le garde des sourds
répondent à ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure oui c'est malheureux que le
garde des sceaux qu'on a entendu avec
tant de ferveur et
de talents plaider les conditions
indignes de la prison
nous disent maintenant assumer de
libérer 13000 détenus c'est pas tout à
fait ça c'est ce sont peut-être juguler
les entrées sous forme de juguler un peu
ce qu'on fait de la comparution
immédiate qui est une justice quand même
expéditive et qui qui remplit le plus
les cellules c'était la plus grande
responsable de enfin pourvoyeuse de
cellules en tout cas
mais comme vous l'avez vu
le procureur général Mollens
prône la régulation carcérale comme et
il est très déçu comme nous l'avons été
de voir que les propositions des états
généraux de la justice n'avaient pas été
repris d'ailleurs Jean-Marc Sauvé m'a
dit lui-même qu'il avait été un peu
frustré et qu'il était déçu de ne pas
pouvoir de ne pas être allé plus loin
dans les propositions sur la régulation
carcérale et sur l'administration
pénitentiaire et s'ils sur la situation
des prisons moi je pense que des forces
qu'on soupçonne pas sont d'accord avec
nous et je veux comme je vous ai donné
par exemple tout à l'heure toutes ces
organisations qui avec nous
ont participé à des discussions pour
formuler des propositions sur la
régulation carcérale
madame de La gontribbe merci beaucoup de
cette question
qui revient finalement à demander à quoi
on sert
quel bilan bah oui quel bilan on tire de
ce qu'on fait et des propositions qu'on
fait est-ce qu'elles sont respectées ou
pas
je dirais que il y a plus
il y a plus à tirer et à retirer de
satisfaction de nos visites sur le
terrain des discussions qu'on a avec les
équipes sur le terrain notamment en
psychiatrie où les équipes j'avoue
fonder font franchement
[Musique]
des discussions très fructueuses avec
eux et qui disent vous avez raison on
était dans notre routine on était perdu
là dedans et on va remédier à ça assis
on va on va on va
juguler si je peux permettre de parler
comme ça l'isolement la contention
on va oui revoir nos procédures le port
du pyjama obligatoire par exemple
l'interdiction d'aller dans le parc les
atteintes à la liberté d'aller devenir
c'est sur le terrain qu'on rencontre les
plus grandes satisfactions
parce que c'est vrai que les autorités
de tutelle
négligent de nous répondre comme le
ministre de l'Intérieur souvent
[Musique]
comme parfois le ministre de la santé
mais on a mis ça au point hier avec lui
de façon franche et
je trouve que c'est dommage mais
finalement si on sert à quelque chose
c'est aussi à faire prendre conscience à
l'opinion publique peut-être en répétant
et à la représentation parlementaire en
répétant sans relâche nos constats et
nos préconisations que vous trouverez
dans nos rapports et dans le rapport
qu'on vous remet aujourd'hui
j'espère que j'ai répondu à tout parce
que
oui sur la psychiatrie en piment sur les
mers avec les
sur le travail mais je suis mille fois
d'accord je suis mille fois d'accord je
vous ai dit le statut du professeur en
prison c'est quand même une honte qu'on
n'y est pas qu'on n'y pense pas plus et
que là on soit obligé de réclamer de
mendier auprès du du
la question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
peut permettre à des gens de faire de la
zumba alors qu'il y a des caissières qui
s'échinent à travailler je le comprends
je comprends très bien non mais non je
vais proposer votre question merci
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président non
c'était absolument un raccourci où je
voulais essayer d'expliquer que il
n'était pas concevable ou une femme en
pleine possession de moyens physiques ne
se réalise pas dans une forme de travail
de façon entre guillemets payer une
dette à la société en créant quelque
chose je suis mille fois d'accord avec
vous
mille fois et on le préconise également
mais simplement la surpopulation
est-elle je vous rappelle le ratio
regardez 70% des détenus travaillent en
Allemagne
ce les 30% qui travaillent pas c'est
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas ou ne
peuvent pas en France c'est 28%. mais
pourquoi
mais parce que premièrement dans les
maisons d'arrêt c'est impossible
d'accéder au travail parce qu'il y a
trop de monde trop de monde quand c'est
quand c'est surpeuplé à 240% 300 %
comment voulait avoir d'accès au travail
ensuite il y a pas accès de travail qui
rentre en prison il faudrait peut-être
assouplir les conditions d'entrée et
voir avec les concessionnaires comment
favoriser l'entrée du travail en prison
c'est c'est
moi j'ai parlé avec des concessionnaires
qui m'ont dit quand à nos un aucun union
un osmirmorque mais deux heures à
pouvoir rentrer dans la prison parce que
à cause des contrôles les mecs en ont
marre et s'en vont
merci beaucoup madame de tous ces
précisions peut-être
un petit mot de
passe j'ai pas répondu
et moi j'en ai rajouté dans le même sens
donc
on est tout à fait d'accord que il faut
mutualiser merci merci
la prison de Gradignan à Bordeaux c'est
un taux d'occupation aujourd'hui de
230%. alors vous savez qu'il y a un
projet de enfin c'est plus qu'un projet
elle est en reconstruction juste à côté
on va nous étions il y a pas très
longtemps mais déjà on sait qu'elle sera
sur occupée de 150%
voilà et sur le travail dans les maisons
dans les prisons Bois-d'Arcy avait
organisé avait mis en place un
dispositif qui doit fonctionner Bordeaux
a du l'arrêter parce qu'il y a plus
d'entreprises qui donnent du travail au
détenu en réalité ce qu'on constate
c'est que moi je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut construire des
prisons parce que ce sera le seul moyen
d'avancer un peu mais c'est pas
suffisant ce sera pas la solution
définitive tant qu'on sera pas capable
d'avoir
des politiques actives en matière
d'exécution des peines sans passer par
la détention enfin tout un système
beaucoup plus cohérent qui n'est
qu'aujourd'hui on ne s'en sortira pas
c'est à dire qu'il faut reprendre le
travail à zéro et qui a un travail de
fond a mené qui est extrêmement lourd
mais démagogie parce que c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que si on pouvait construire
faire
les murs on a du travail merci Madame
pour votre présence
merci aux collègues ne partez pas tout
de suite les collègues j'ai encore deux
choses à vous demander